[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what is
making the headlines
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce and the associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
welcome and great to see both of you so
as ever let's take a look shall we at
the front pages starting with the metro
the only way is ethics that's how the
metro describes the announcement that
boris johnson's ethics advisor lord guyt
has quit over his concerns about
partygate the ayah also makes that
resignation its front page lead
the telegraph 2 which says lord guyt is
concerned that the pm breached the
ministerial code over the parties at
downing street
the guardian says the latest resignation
piles more pressure on a beleaguered
boris johnson
the times uh taking a similar line about
the growing pressure on the pm
and the halting of the government's
first flight of migrants to rwanda is
the lead for the express
with an attack by the home secretary on
the european court of human rights while
the daily mail says the government may
just ignore such interventions in the
future
financial times meanwhile leading with
that news of a rise in u.s interest
rates as the federal reserve tries to
tackle worsening inflation
and please save beatrix the mirror has
an exclusive about a couple who donated
their still-born child's heart to save
another youngster and now need a donor
organ for their own 16 month old
daughter
and to the star it says hallelujah we're
about to get a pill that will replace
the need to go to the gym and that a
pint of lager a day is good for your
health
right
a quick reminder by scanning the qr
codes you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch our guests so let's return then to
andrew pearce and kevin mcguire and uh
perhaps not surprisingly andrew lord
guyt making many a front page um to be
fair it was a very brief statement from
him um
is it supposition why he left
well it's all very odd isn't it the
timing it came out just before six
o'clock so great for for the for the
newspapers because it's late breaking
news one sentence is his resignation uh
uh you would have thought if he was
going to resign on it it would have been
when he published his annual report uh
was critical of partygate sensed a sense
of frustration boris johnson then
responding saying he had no intention of
resigning everyone thought that was the
moment when he was going to go we were
told he could be going within hours but
he stayed uh some suggestion that the
prime minister had persuaded him to stay
then he gives evidence yesterday and in
a classic old whitehall um piece of
evidence he didn't really say very much
but it's what he didn't say spoke volume
so
you got the clear inference that he
thought prime minister had reached the
ministerial code but he didn't say so
and he still didn't resign and then 24
hours later when nobody's expecting it
he goes i suspect he dwelt on what was
said at that select committee yesterday
he read the papers today he thought
about it and he just thought
it's just too uncomfortable so he's gone
whether he's going to give us any more
details i suspect he won't because he's
not a man who likes running to the press
talking to the press as much as we'd
like to talk to him yes trained in that
with his work in buckingham palace no
doubt but um yeah yes you know
suggesting to mps it was reasonable to
suggest the prime minister had broken
the ministerial code uh by breaching
those lockdown laws and then what would
he do about that that was that was kind
of the point kevin wasn't it
yeah given that boris johnson is judging
jury on himself
which does seem uh it's always been the
position but it just seems to be wrong
where you think perhaps parliament
should decide although that mps will be
whipped uh whoever's in in power will
whip their mps and then you can just say
no no no breach but the telegraph point
out he considered going last december
over the prime minister's wallpaper when
it cleared uh boris johnson over who
paid for his wallpaper and then messages
uh came out that showed he didn't know
who was paying for his wallpaper the
prime minister claiming he claiming he
hadn't and telegraph again point out
the last epic
ethics adviser alex allen went in
november uh 2020 after the report into
bullying by pretty patel the home
secretary which the prime minister
effectively in or ignored she made a
statement uh apologizing and that was it
but the telegraph also quote i see
william rag who's chair of the public
administration committee conservative mp
critic of boris johnson who's
praising geit's integrity so the focus
is back on the prime minister's own
uh position his uh integrity or lack of
his honor or lack of
his personal conduct which which isn't
good and he would have thought after
partygate last week each shifted on he'd
moved away from it but seems not
yeah
and is there a pattern of behavior
emerging um from boris johnson you know
the the fixed penalty notice he got with
the cake the ambushing of the cake
moment we all remember it you know that
was the unwitting bit that boyce johnson
said and the downing street flat
refurbishment you know he'd explained to
lord guyt um
you know that he hadn't hadn't known he
hadn't realized where the money was
coming from and then obviously these
messages as as kevin was explaining were
revealed um you know it keeps being
unwitting doesn't it is that the defense
from from this prime minister andrew
well look
boris johnson and has had an interesting
relationship with the truth there's no
doubt about that
now whether it's because he's just not
great on detail which i suspect he isn't
and people know that but lord guy could
have resigned over the wallpaper because
the prime minister said he wasn't sure
who was paying for it then what's that
messages came to like which suggested he
did know it's a tory donor called lord
brownlow i suspect if that had been
public money involved i the taxpayer had
been involved in decorating the downy
street flat um lord guy would have gone
but as it was it was a tory donut nor he
got a period no suggestion he got
anything out of it but it was an odd
episode actually but i still think it's
very odd that guy
i mean he's he's had a stellar career in
the civil service he was the queen's
private secretary cutely respected in
buckingham palace and why he's gone now
is just so very odd because the time to
go it would have had much more dramatic
effect in my view was at the time when
boris johnson was under huge pressure
over partygate and although this has
projected it back to the front pages
today tomorrow i suspect it would let me
stay there for a couple of days unless
there's something new about to come out
about those parties but i can't see what
that can be because we've had sue grey's
report and that was pretty exhaustive uh
so it feels to me like in a sense um
the maximum point of danger for the
prime minister has already passed yeah
but but lord law guy may not be trying
to make impacts you know this is not
about political damage in fact the
guardian picks up on what you said kevin
um to read the guardian it is understood
that the robust evidence session
confirmed in guide's mind that his
position was no longer tenable one
person who had spoken to him said he was
sick of being lied to another said geit
was frustrated at his portrayal as a
patsy and after what one friend called a
long night of the soul guy sent this uh
strongly worded letter to boss johnson
now will we will we get sight of that do
you think um and or already labor um
saying that boss johnson has driven both
of his own hand-picked ethics advisers
to resign and despair as they put it
he has that's presumably because boris
johnson is uh is very very very
unethical andrew was talking about a
strange relationship to the truth boris
johnson's a complete stranger to the
truth he's just very very rarely
truthful i think what he is truthful is
probably accidental uh
you read that you read that in the
garden like guy isn't an assassin he
hasn't quit to take out the prime
minister there isn't a political agenda
there i think after that incredibly
uncomfortable hearing yesterday
it's true he he appeared a patsy
i'd call him a patsy myself in the past
i used to joke if i was ever accused of
anything serious i i wanted to be
investigated by gait because he wouldn't
you wouldn't get the root of it you'd
won't certainly be cleared he'd believe
anything you say
and off you and off you go
and i suspect that has all just mounted
up and he and he realized that whatever
he was being paid whatever
perks he got whatever status he enjoyed
from that position it was damaging him
it was undermining him as he as andrew
said he's got a long distinguished
career in the civil service he was the
queen's secretary and that was all just
being sort of washed away and the stain
was going to be there that he was the
ethics adviser for an incredibly
unethical prime minister so he's adding
up but as for that letter i would like
to see that i would like to see that
letter i'd like to see that letter in
fall i think we should see that letter
whether we do or not
is another matter of course
yeah danny street
i apologize kevin um the metro um you
know as we all have read ourselves
downing street did not comment
officially a source insisted we are
surprised this is a mystery to the pm
only on monday he said he would like to
stay on for another six months but this
idea of boris johnson having an
interesting relationship with the truth
as you put it do you think after
partygate the public want to see
you know that being cleaned up that
actually we want a bit more
straightforwardness now from uh from
those in downey street andrew
of course and uh partygate look
partygate was a very damaging episode
for the prime minister people in number
10. it was a very unedifying episode
lots of people who we don't need to
rehearse all the reasons why but
the great british public mostly obeyed
the rules and then we discovered there
was a flagrant breaching of the rules in
number 10 the prime minister fined just
the one time some people thought he
should have been fine more often but
that was up to the police yeah of course
he's got to be he's got to be and he'll
have been told this by tory mps
remember he lost the support of 41
percent of them in that conference just
a couple of weeks ago
which already seems anna like a lifetime
ago because politics is moving so
quickly and so rapidly and changing so
fast at the moment but i suspect when uh
he was before that 1922 committee of mps
they said you've got to prevent any more
of these
sort of episodes which sap his moral
authority
now this is an uncomfortable
moment for the prime minister again but
it goes back to something that's already
been well rehearsed and well ventilated
and which we already know a lot about in
a sense nothing new there yes and in
fact i think it was only last week
wasn't it as you said it's going fast
and this was supposed to be part of a
free week for the pm wasn't it but we'll
move on to uh to other matters after
this quick break including uh rob's
threat to ignore euro court rulings
that's on the front page of the daily
mail as the government rails against the
blocking of the first flight first
deportation flight to rwanda
[Music]
[Music]
watching the press preview with me now
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce and kevin mcguire
associate editor of the daily mirror
welcome back to both of you um so kevin
let's go to the daily mail shall we um
what to do about rwanda after the
intervention of the of the european
court which we heard so much about today
um and the threat from dominic raab to
do what about that euro court ruling
yeah he according to the mail it's been
brief that he may i say may
ignore late rulings by uh the european
court of human rights which uh remind
those who
are brexit obsessed it has nothing to do
with the european
union that may uh i think is very uh
very heavy and hanging
because
look the prime minister hinted uh
britain could pull out i suspect britain
won't but how many fights do you want
with the rest of the world do you want
to stop it and try and get off it do you
want to debase standards just
not not respect
standards that are seen in other
civilized countries or or will you
follow them and look
the whole rwanda
program whatever you think about it
whether you think it is right or wrong
was an utter shambles not least because
the government tried to rush it through
for pr reasons and hadn't allowed people
to exhaust the legal system on whether
or not they could could be sent
so dominick robb wants to pick a fight
with somebody else as pretty patel
doesn't as boris johnson does but in the
end it's another failure by probably the
most incompetent uk government and
living memory yes and uh obviously you
know separately we had the european
commission taking legal action of the
northern ireland protocol but as you're
right this has got nothing to do with
the european union um but this idea of
actually pulling out of the european
convention of human rights which
underpins that court i mean belarus
isn't a member and earlier this year
russia got thrown out of the council of
europe so do we want to be associated
with countries like that andrew on this
well you know the first the first prime
minister to float the idea of
withdrawing from it was actually theresa
may and nobody sees her as a foaming
flicker foaming at the mouth of
brexiteer she was an arch remainer
because she just didn't really
have much respect for that call look the
court the high court and the court of
appeal both cleared that flight to go
ahead to rwanda so frankly what business
is it of the european court to stick its
big great nose in it and it's a gift for
the talk for the tory party and
brexiteers because they'll say here you
go again
kevin's quite right it's not the
european union but it's the european
court but sticking its name we don't
even know the name of the judge who
presided they don't even tell you that
and you know some of the people who
preside over these european court
rulings aren't even judges they're
high-powered lawyers it's not the same
and i think there were five judges
involved in the british legal process
one unnamed legal figure in the european
court verdict so i would prefer the
british legal verdict frankly to the
european court one and i think uh i
would be
wary about withdrawing from that whole
convention in the european court but a
few more incidents like that and you can
see why the government will go down that
route and i think actually it'll be very
popular
yes and the european under i don't know
why you just stop
why do you stop at the european
convention on you and that's why do you
withdraw from the un and the geneva
convention well why not
[Music]
uh the ilo the world health organized
why do you just pull out of them all
look the whole idea of joining is you
have common standards and their common
standards of decency the european
convention of human rights has helped
improve the mental health of people in
britain well job right work right
abolishing
you've never had anything
incredibly progressive but we signed up
to it and don't forget okay
okay
after the second world war to have
standards across
europe that were decent
yeah okay kevin i hear that i hear
you're foaming at the mouth rant british
judiciary is the envy of the world and
i'm quite content the british judicial
standards are just as good as the
european the european court and the
european convention we can have our own
bill of rights what's wrong with that
why do you never ever want anything to
be british kevin it's always got to be
european always the european court
ruling was to allow the judicial review
of this of this policy to take place
next month but we'll leave it there for
now gentlemen we've run out of time
sadly kevin mcguire andrew pearce thank
you both very much indeed